همم كان همم ورد ساكن ابريل اورج
اورجنسيشن ساردين فرنسيه
قد ايه
سويسرا
[موسيقى]
وان تتحمل روسيا سلوكها
عدوانها على اوكرانيا كما شاهدنا نحن
بحاجه
لاقامه علاقات واتصالات المغرب
[موسيقى]
متعلق
بانيته وروسيا وهذه الحوارات الجاريه
حاليا قبل ان ناخذ السؤال التالي
نحن نتحدث عن البحر الاسود كالنقطه
استراتيجيه كما اتفق عليه في قمه مدريد
هذا الصيف هل يمكن ان يكون هناك
استراتيجيه بوجود ثلاث دول
هل يمكن ان تعالج هذه القضيه نعم البحر
الاسود هو ذو اهميه كبيره همم
عفو همم
2014 زدنا وجودنا في منطقه البحر الاسود
ونعمل عن كتب مع اثنتين من الدول
البحر الاسود وهذا قمنا به قبل الحرب وان
يوصلها حتى الان نعم هذه المنطقه تتطلب
منها
يواجه كل التحديات في المنطقه
وهذا همم
هذه
التحالف في مواجهه هذه القضيه
لانها لديها اكبر حدود بريه مع اوكرانيا
الانتشار السريع لقوه للنشر سريع لقواته
فهناك دبابات فرنسيه
تحركت
وشاهدنا ذلك
اذا كان لها دور مهم جدا في
الدعم لاوكرانيا
اكبر حدود بريه مع اوكرانيا
لاوكرانيا مهم جدا من دعم الانساني
الرومانيه
والرساله ستكون واضحه بان علينا ان نحافظ
على هذا الدم
وخاصه انظمه الدفاع الجوي لمساعده همم
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها جوا وبرا وبحرا
بالطبع كما تعلمون فان رومانيا تستضيف عدد
كبير من همم اللاجئين اييي من عبروا
الحدود
ااه وذهبوا الى دول مختلفه في اوروبا وهذه
مساله مهمه تبين
الدعم الساخي لاوكرانيا ولا الاوكرانيين
الذين اضطروا لمغادره بلادهم علينا ان
نتفهم انه عندما حدث الغزو نيته لم تفاجا
بل كنا نعده
مثل هذا العدوان منذ
من هذا العام لكنها لم تبدا الان بل بدات
في ربيعي 2014 عندما كان هناك همم
طيب الدفاعات اثنين بالمئه من رومانيا
وغيرها من الحلفاء
لدينا معلومات
استخباراتيه قبل ذلك باشهر منذ خريف 21
العام الماضي نعرف ان روسيا تنويه غزوه
اوكرانيا
التحرك الروسي
التحرك الروسي همم زدنا وجودنا في المنطقه
اليوم
قررنا التحرك الدفاعي وزياده وجودنا لم
نكن مس- غير مستعدين ابدا
2014 حتى 2022
نفاجا بل تصرفنا خلال تلك الفتره لزياده
وجودنا واستعدادنا وجاهزينا وكثير من
الحلفاء فرنسا كانت بزياء كانت هي القائد
في قوات التي تحركت لتكون جاهزه
وراينا في بحر البلطيق وفي ااه المتوسط
تعزيز للقوات والقوات الجويه ايضا وكنا
جاهزين
برامج 2018
خدمه الناس
وحول هيكليه ال ال الاستجابه
كانت رد الاوكراني سريع وكذلك الولايات
المتحده كحاليف ايضا ماذا نتوقع
من بحث لهذه القضيه في المستقبل
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وغير من الدول الذين
يقدمون المساعدات
لاوكرانيا والمساعده العسكريه هي الاهم
والاكثر حساسيه في همم هذا
تحالف بقياده الامريكيه
وايضا هناك جهد عالمي لدعم